what happened in 1941 on a tuesday at 10
a.m is not going to help me today
whenever he got a [ __ ] up power well
what i'm saying
you know some mutants right some mutants
have cool powers like colossus is a cool
one but there's probably ones like
there's one called dead girl
oh there's a dead girl there's i think
there's one called dead girl but she's
like from like um x-men z like some
younger generation what didn't mean
she can't die remember mojo he was just
like a big fat blob what did he do
that's not mojo mojo was a big fan of
the blob with the blob now go to go mojo
or x-men
you remember the blob though i know a
blob
a movie no mojo i had an x-men card i
have a whole collection how
oh wow okay
mojo
oh yeah he is
yeah what did you what did mojo do
let's see he is
oh my god caleb do you want to go
through all this no that's not it's all
right i mean just one thing this is
riveting yeah
their powers powers and abilities go
down
mojo is a powerful sorcerer the full
limits of his magical knowledge is
unknown he is also a master manipulator
and schemer
like a base like a new yorker basically
yeah yeah he's in new york why does he
have to be a blob with that power i know
but you know his card was very strong
that's how you remember it as a kid wow
all right yeah
if i was an x-men i get [ __ ] like i
would get like
like my anus would turn into steel and
that's it yeah
i've said this before yeah but it's like
the fact that it's like you want that to
be your power a steel angle so he didn't
cut off so what what is the yeah what is
the point of that
that's why there's no point so everyone
has these powers right right and i'm
going like you're i'm angry and i got it
but it's like stealing i'm angry i got
it but there's nothing i can do
they would have to hold you up you know
yeah yeah yeah it's like a shield and
then your anus would like block things
or maybe they have a like a stick of
plutonium
we don't know what to do with it and
they just oh they get in here i have a
use for it no cigar night you know
you're you we're well the guys are
hanging out having cigars
you would bend over we would just go
click you would get it and we'd be like
oh thanks mommy
or if you got if you get shot just turn
your anus to the incoming bullet
right but what if it hits my cheek i'm
done
oh that's the one well there's a lot of
cheek so i guess
it is like spread wide babe yeah yeah
i also had this uh joke i could never
get work but i this was a bit i did oh
so the other joke was the other power i
would have is uh
i would control ants
would that be a great power that's a
great power no but watch so like like
you know saber tooth attacks me okay
right
and i go stop he goes
what are you gonna do
and me going they're coming
and we just stand there for like three
hours and all of a sudden you see these
ants slowly getting to him well you're
not utilizing ants in the way that
they're meant to be utilized what do you
mean because ants are master builders
right yeah so i would have them like
yeah you can't have them on like a last
minute basis they're not there to help
you in that way they're there to help
you set up traps set up other stuff
build things
oh there is an ant man i know there's ed
but that's not what i'm talking about
kalila what right the exasperation about
this nerdy topic it's like
hilarious
like he was like telling this one oh you
don't get it
have you not seen an ex movie it's like
i've seen all of them i know but you
know when action starts it's happening
there's
so the guy that can control anne's wife
oh the egg guy would have ants in his
belt
he'd have ants in a backpack and he
would just like open him up get him yeah
that is true you just have them attached
to you already why why are you still
calling on to them yeah where are they
that you're like all right so magneto's
up right he's
bending steel yeah right he's uh 300
feet away bending steel right uh-huh and
i have a backpack full of ants yeah
giant red and that's all it's itchy as
[ __ ] no you're you know you're immune to
it you're like
i take the backpack but me on cyclops is
looking at me like
he does one of these oh this guy
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you
brought that guy no no no listen yeah
you're not on the field with cyclops
like no you're who am i where are you
you're at the mansion you know what i
mean like you're the gardener you're
making sure all the ants are holding
again yeah yeah yeah you're not oh
ancillary you really think that like
they're gonna be like who are we
bringing with us all right storm
cyclops
yeah yeah professor xavier yeah and then
ant boy
yeah yeah yeah there's no way you're not
on that list i'm not on the list you're
not you're not you're not yeah yeah
rogue wouldn't even touch you to take
your powers
that's true that's super annoying that
would be true
yeah what power would you have you think
i don't know
probably some nose power or something
like power smell oh that's good that is
a real superpower i know but it would be
like it would be terrible you've never
seen that before
have you seen that no that's interesting
no but those are real things like super
smellers are a real thing that medical
researchers use like if you're somebody
that has a very keen sense of smell you
are likely able to predict early onset
parkinson's and other major diseases
right so you're basically what you are
right you rumor on the mansion
right and you smell like wolverine i
find that and then you have you go
yeah you have a tumor
and wolverine's like really he's a good
doctor yeah yeah he's a doctor you're
basically just a bloodhound yeah you're
a bloodhound and i always know when
somebody farts right right first like
you see people come up to you it's like
i can't find my ham sandwich
right and then you were like walking
around the mansion you left it on the
you know i mean it's right there right
there like we would be a that would be
the terrible duo
sniffy and ant and cat boy no and no an
iron hole iron
oh that's the anus thing that'd be
sniffy and iron hole iron
yeah yeah hey guys we're gonna take a
really quick break to share some of our
favorite sponsors with you
roman roman roman get your dickie going